it's [ __ ] nuts i forgot and then he
had to redo it but with ritz yep shout
out to ritz and shout out to ritz yeah
still [ __ ] out there slugging still
out there
race is going to ritz man i can tell you
this ain't nobody out rapping ritz i
don't disagree i mean he knows this he
knows how i feel about him no ain't
nobody out rapping ritz man
you know when when he's in his bag ain't
nobody [ __ ] with that dude man i just
hope one day ritz can have an honest
bio book because he has some of the
craziest stories that he can never tell
on camera oh it's [ __ ] it's a wild
boy that no that dude's [ __ ] nuts i'm
a little crazy he's a lunatic crazy yeah
he's a [ __ ] lunatic yeah he's crazy
bro it's been cool watching that whole
scene and everybody grow the way they
have for sure for sure even like a guy
like caskey you know caskey's uh he
records here he just really just did his
album here yeah
i love love what he's doing um
you know y'all talked about on the
podcast obviously we all got in a weird
spot because caskey ended up
like dissing some other dudes that we
associate with in the circuit and it's
like
i'm glad i'm glad this somehow
paralleled into this because you know
what hurts me about that whole situation
is watching a bunch of really good dudes
that don't know each other
have a problem with each other and me
knowing every one of them personally
and being like y'all are all really good
dudes though like if you guys ever
actually hung out yeah like if you knew
adam calhoun's heart
and that dude is a [ __ ] sweetheart
man he's a good [ __ ] father
he's a dedicated you know he's just like
a good dude that's fair you know what
i'm saying like it's like if you knew
that about him like how much he
celebrates other people winning and how
much he's one of the first texts i get
every time i do something cool
you him there's a group of people that
every time something even looks cool
he's one of the first texas like such a
sweetheart
casca i've watched since he was a kid
like that he's a great dude like
caskey's not a bad yeah i don't know
what the
root of their issue is i think that uh
you know what i think man this is what i
truly think i think that
during the pandemic
uh
and i'm a i'm like a really
independently thinking guy i kind of
consider myself like more in like the
joe rogan lane of politics right
socially liberal
i wanna i wanna i wanna protect my
family i want to be able to you know
obviously within reason have access to
weapons and you know i do feel like
18 year old kids who just graduated high
school shouldn't be able to go buy two
ar-15s without taking a class or
something right
i'm not saying take the guns right just
like you know maybe go through a course
before you get something like that but
i do think that like a guy like adam
calhoun
who i didn't know anything about except
for
when caskey because i'm close with
caskey right of course and then the
first thing i just see
is all this politics [ __ ] this you know
the mag of [ __ ] and to me
i'm like alright well
anybody who rides that it'd be like if
there was a joe like a rapper riding for
joe biden i'd be like crazy right what
the [ __ ] wrong with you for sure and
so you know and that's why like
i i like when i saw that i'm just like
yeah dude like i i don't know i don't
get that [ __ ] and and to me like at the
end of the day people make music for all
types of audiences right and you know
i think a guy like struggle is like a
perfect example of somebody who may feel
however he feels but he's just making
music and he's not like
making
it in a divisive way that makes fans
feel
that they have to
shoot like if does that make sense what
i'm saying no totally it's like
that makes more sense than anything
and i live in the complete opposite
world of everybody
i don't have an opinion about this [ __ ]
at all
like i hate our government i hated our
government with every president we've
had since i was like 14 because they
charged me as an adult
for a crime i committed when i was
[ __ ] 15 years old they took every
right i have away from and because of
that i am personally protesting our
government i have been forever right
it's like i don't give a [ __ ] i think
it's all
a divide and conquer thing i think a
two-party system is just meant for
failure
right
so i don't get them wrapped up but none
of that [ __ ] um
but my thing is too is that
this is i tell you this story and this
is where it changed my perspective
my brother's here he knows this to be
true
my father
was i don't think i've ever said this
publicly
my father was
a progressive man he probably leaned a
little liberal in his older age right
my uncle was a progressive man that
leaned a little conservative in his
older age they grew up together three
years apart best [ __ ] friends from
birth right 70 in their 70s
my father was more of a methodist church
kind of man which is
a kind of a portion of a catholic thing
not a portion but it rides that
offensive kind of direct to the
scripture
real stand-up prey simple you know my
uncle at the time especially was more of
a pentecostal guy which is more of you
know
you know there's a big difference right
um
one day when my dad was dying i said
how have you and uncle beef have been
best friends for all these years
and y'all don't agree
about anything
my father set me straight he said what
are you talking we don't agree about
anything
he said we slightly disagree about two
things
we agree about a thousand things right
he's like i don't understand why the
world wants to talk about the two things
they don't agree about
instead of the thousand things we can
make progress with that we do agree
right
and that just changed the way i look at
life you know what i'm saying it's like
immediately i look past it so i guess
it's like even with the [ __ ] i don't
think
i'm old school enough to think that you
know
i don't know what i think about politics
being in the music right it's been
around as long as we've been around we
have talked about public enemies
public enemies making protest music rage
against the machine it's been happening
of course so
you know it's funny i was thinking about
it like when adam and them first started
rapping i would look at that like oh
dude these dudes are
like this isn't protest music they're
agreeing with the government
and then there's a
regime switch in america
right the the part the political parties
changes and suddenly it's like oh that's
protest music now and that just showed
me how unstable the foundation of
america is in itself right yeah i mean i
guess with that dude i you know
i don't know much about um
his whole catalog i guess i've just seen
a few well he's got some stuff that's
really dope but then i've seen like uh
there's but then there's other guys like
you know i'll see like uh the dude from
florida uh what's that dude's name the
maga rapper dude
yeah now that to me to me that [ __ ] is
just corny it's corny to me because i
know what he was doing before he was
doing that he was doing the blue hair
[ __ ] bootleg riff-raff [ __ ] i lived
for sure same people no 100 he was doing
like the uh the white rick ross thing
right yeah
his angle and
to each their own to me it's like low
hanging fruit for sure and it's like the
artist the artistic integrity is like yo
you're kind of like
putting all your eggs in this basket
right but that basket has a ceiling
that's this high for sure no i guess
when you've been making shitty rap music
for as long as that guy has any fandom
you're gonna be like well i'm making
money over here so i'm gonna lean into
this [ __ ] but to me it's just like
divisive but i do think like i said like
you know it's important like
for me
if i
if i don't agree with somebody
on certain [ __ ] i like i have i have
people in my life who will cut people
off based on like their opinion on one
or two things oh yeah and to me that's
never like uh productive oh it's like
and i guess that that goes back to my
thing with them was like
i know adam outside of the music i know
caskey outside of the music i know
everybody was politically charged in
that moment except for jelly roll cause
[ __ ] our government forever
but
it's one of those things where like i
know these dudes to be good dudes
so you look when that happens and you're
like
just not necessary i wish i could get
you all together to just like talk like
responsible dudes are like you know what
i mean like y'all have so much like
y'all would actually have a whole lot of
tons of comments yeah they're gonna have
a [ __ ] hilarious conversation
um
tom mcdonald's the same way right you
know he's from canada right yeah yeah
he's from canada but he's [ __ ] you
know i don't i don't like again like i
did um because he's independent and i i
i uh
i'm also kind of like like when you know
he does a lot of the youtube rap [ __ ]
like you know
and um i watched a vlog he did about
uh him and that dude's album
being [ __ ] on billboard
and i watched that because i was
actually interested in that because i'm
like yo as an independent artist that's
crazy what that dude's doing i might not
[ __ ] with his music right but it's
insane the business he's built right and
it's like just him and his girl yeah for
sure no that's the [ __ ] i can look past
and i'm like yo this is this is
respectable like you know like i might
not agree with like i might not be a fan
of like his [ __ ] like it's just not for
me but i can at least appreciate an
independent artist doing that kind of
[ __ ] that shit's crazy he's got a record
he put out called scars it's like a rock
kind of driven record that's [ __ ]
incredible songwriting and that's kind
of where i live with everybody right i'm
just always looking for
i don't know i guess i'm a songwriter so
i'm kind of overwhelmed and all that
other [ __ ] anyways so i'm like does he
have a song i thought was written really
well and adam's got a few cass he's got
a lot yellow wolf's got more than
probably anybody struggle's got to tell
them these are dudes that i'm just like
ritz that i can just look at and be like
yo i don't
you know i don't give a [ __ ] if you
were the biggest buying supporter on
earth this song [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like this i tell you this much
it's like listen r kelly's a piece of
[ __ ] i love his music you're not going
to get me to quit listening to our wish
i agree you just can't do that to me
dude i'm sorry cancel me
[ __ ] it how about this somebody from the
artist somebody cover it then
but don't take a song that i played at
funerals away from me
because this man's a scumbag somebody
cover it like don't tell me something
about michael jackson and the human
nature is one of my favorite songs ever
you know somebody cover it up if there's
a better version out there i'll bump it
you're saying that's for sure but it's
like man that [ __ ] suck dude i've
cried dozens of tears that i wish it's a
great record i love our i mean our
kelly's probably my favorite r b singer
ever outside of him being a piece of
[ __ ] strictly discography
yeah you know if i didn't know his name
or know that he pissed on little girls
right or watched the [ __ ] wild r
kelly series that was [ __ ] nuts
oh my god right if i didn't know that it
was just the voice through the radar i'd
be like yo this [ __ ] slaps yeah
it's it's